the Joe Rogan experience Oh what do you
like are just automatically web for my
glass
so bombs October we're not with are we
doing gas money garage fires lighting a
fire it's over October and oh my gosh
what are we doing you bring in the bail
foundation
oh you want the temptation start
clanging very well what do you want you
are you I'll just put some glasses oh my
god ring that Bell
ring that Bell right now in front of it
Oh dan Aykroyd gave us a massive speech
on how good that vodkas that's his huh
mmm yeah smell its mom you see it or if
you take a little sip I'm not gonna be
mad at you
damn it smells very good vodka he
explained this process they use their
diamonds they actually have some sort of
[ __ ] diamonds that they use to filter
it let Burt smell it smell it smell it
just have some Oh fry yeah we can still
do this challenge stuff now be sober for
most of October for January it's just
need a little more easily
ease it up a little bit smells good
right suppose it does it's very good it
smells Ganic or gave me a hell of a
sales pitch yeah no yeah the holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] right he he sold I can't
imagine doing coke with that guy alright
he talks it yeah talks very good talker
yeah he develops a podcast lately thank
you he believes a lot of nonsense he
does oh my god everything channelers
psychics looking you name it
alright thank you whatever he he doesn't
there's not a goddamn thing
it's all poor and we'll all put it to
our lips and we'll see if anyone opens
their mouth
and what happens when they do the month
is over those the month is over no you
just keep going yeah you want it never
little sip have a sip
so we're doing on the first more than 30
days left right now
yeah there's 30 and 100 Mayan Count
calendar the only it's already over
we're all dead December twenty first two
thousand is that Khumbu to have alcohol
in it yeah look man
since since the challenge isn't like as
intense like does the sobriety really
matter no do we even John the surprise
October so so Bob doc told us and the
problem is re and I already got higher
earlier we were smoking cigars and we
both got a buzz no doubt about it so
it's over
the silver part I think all right I
cheated I think it I think it should be
over that's like that's a I feel like we
did it wrong yup how bad go to Europe
why would you do that sober how about
with every drink you take you have to do
an additional class oh I love this oh my
god my dick just got hard every drink is
a class oh quit [ __ ] are we really
doing this every drink is a class you
could start from zero with that every
drink is that for us drink is an actual
drink is it drinks you have ten classes
at uo period then if you drink every
drink is an additional class if you have
three drinks tonight you have three more
classes through thirteen classes yes
that's impossible that'll they'll never
be able to get that many yeah zero a
legit drink you can't be like a [ __ ]
beer stifled
what about does weed apply to the same
thing yeah yeah every time you take a
hit and that's it I mean do you realize
just for one night of drinking I would
do - there'll be no time you would never
be able to have strong zero class
classes a day for the whole month wait
one night yeah what is one night for
real we're doing doubles all right like
what's a double or one for if I'm like
if I'm on the road I'll have I'll bring
a double on stage with me I'll have a
double after the show I have a double at
the bar I have a double embossing warmer
done - it's a 4x8 drink so that would be
fun well then set you straight
well you'd be like I'm straight right
now or like you stop the shakes with
stop times of course there were times I
couldn't use chopsticks in Japan at the
airport one Hey yeah dude what gets me
is those long flights because I drink on
long flights
so what [ __ ] me up you do it oh yeah do
it just do it out of class I like that
for every drink we do we have to add a
class I would I would do it was talking
from zero Tober that's not the thing is
just people listening to this they're
either severely disappointed first of
all on me for bringing in shot glasses
and ice definitely angry right now a lot
of them I really look forward to doing
this already angry at re-birth the
victim no you're a [ __ ] rapist yes
you're very bad
you might out beat Bill Cosby you didn't
like the Welch holy [ __ ] you see the
nicknames coming your way
[Applause]